♪ ♪
>> KAMALA HARRIS ONCE AGAIN TREY
DEAN HAD WAKES IN THE
ADMINISTRATION.
A TV HOST BY THE NAME OF
CHARLEMAGNE THAT GOD AFTER HE
ASKED THIS TOUGH QUESTION.
>> WHO IS THE REAL PRESIDENT OF
THE COUNTRY?
>> COME ON.
>> IT'S JOE BIDEN.
NO, NO, NO, NO.
IT'S JOE BIDEN.
AND DON'T START TALKING LIKE A
REPUBLICAN ABOUT ASKING WHETHER
OR NOT HE IS PRESIDENT.
>> DO YOU THINK JOE MANCHIN IS A
PROBLEM?
>> IT'S JOE BIDEN AND MY NAME IS
KAMALA HARRIS.
>> THERE ARE OTHER SEGMENTS TO
THIS INTERVIEW --
>> Greg: THE BEST PART YOU
DIDN'T EVEN CLIP WAS WHEN HE
LOOKED OVER TO THE SIDE AND HE
GOES OH, THEY CAN HEAR ME.
THE THING IS, HOW BAD IS THIS
WHEN YOU ARE WITH SIMONE SANDERS
IN THE CONTROL ROOM AND IT'S --
HE OF THE MOST BENEVOLENT
SITUATION AND IT STILL THAT BAD.
THAT IS WHY SHE CAN'T DO OTHER
INTERVIEWS.
I HAVE A FEELING THAT THEY WANT
AN ENTIRE CLEAN SLATE FOR 2024.
IT IS KIND OF LIKE AFTER A CAR
ACCIDENT OR WHEN YOUR CAR GETS
STOLEN AND ITS RETURN AND YOU
JUST WANT THE INSURANCE COMPANY
TO TOTAL THE CAR.
YOU DON'T WANT TO REPAIR THE
RACK.
IT'S LIKE -- IT'S JUST NOT THE
SAME ANYMORE, EVEN WHEN THEY
BRING IT INTO THE SHOP, IT STILL
HAS THAT SMELL.
YOU JUST WANT TO GET A NEW CAR.
THAT IS WHAT THE DEMS WANT.
TOTAL LIT, THEY NEED AN
INSURANCE COMPANY TO COME IN.
>> SIMONE SANDERS IS LEAVING
KAMALA HARRIS' OFFICE AT THE END
OF THIS MONTH.
SHE WAS SAYING WE CAN'T HEAR THE
QUESTION.
RIGHT AS KAMALA HARRIS WAS ABOUT
TO ANSWER THE QUESTION.
>> I THINK THAT SIMONE HAS DONE
HER BEST.
SHE SETS UP AN INTERVIEW FOR,
HAS THAT IS GOING TO BE FRIENDLY
AND THEY KNOW IT'S GOING TO BE.
I HAVE A DIFFERENT VIEW ABOUT
THIS.
I THINK THIS INTERVIEW HELPED
KAMALA HARRIS.
SHE NEEDS TO HAVE MORE
CONFIDENCE IN HER.
MIDTERM ELECTIONS ARE NOT ABOUT
INDEPENDENT SWING VOTERS WHO
SHOW UP ONCE IN A WHILE FOR A
MIDTERM.
THESE ARE ABOUT BASED ELECTIONS.
THAT IS THE KAMALA I'VE MISSED,
THAT IS THE KAMALA I WANT TO
SEE, SO I'VE A FEELING THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE A LOT MORE
OF THAT.
>> WHO KNEW HE WAS CHARLEMAGNE
THE NEWSMAKER?
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME.
HE WAS THE ONE WHO HAD CANDIDATE
JOE BIDEN ON WHEN HE SAID, IF
YOU DON'T VOTE FOR ME YOU ARE
NOT BLACK.
>> HE IS A LIBERAL AND HE TELLS
PEOPLE THIS.
BUT HE HOLDS PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE
BASED ON THE THINGS THEY SAID
THAT THEY WERE GOING TO DO.
AND THAT IS THE PURPOSE, KAMALA
WAS NOT PREPARED.
I AGREE TO A CERTAIN EXTENT THAT
IT HELPED HER AT THE END,
BECAUSE HE GAVE HER A PIECE OF
ADVICE.
IN THE FUTURE, THEY WANT TO SEE
THE PROSECUTOR THAT WAS WITH THE
REPUBLICANS WHEN YOU GROW
REPUBLICANS WOULD THE DONALD
BILL MACDONALD TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WAS IN THERE.
BUT SHE STILL DIDN'T ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
WE KNOW HE WASN'T SUGGESTING
THAT JOE BIDEN WAS IN THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
THE QUESTION WAS, WHO HAS THE
MOST POWER?
AND SHE REFUSED TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION.
ALSO FOLLOWED UP BY SAYING, IS
JOE MANCHIN A PROBLEM?
AND THEN SHE GOT TO DO THIS
WHOLE THING ABOUT HER BEING THE
VP AND EVERYONE KNOWS THAT AND
THEN SHE HAD A GREAT MOMENT AT
THE END WHERE SHE WAS AGGRESSIVE
AND -- BUT THERE WAS NO
SUBSTANCE THERE, WHICH IS HER
PROBLEM.
SHE HAS GREAT MOMENTS WHEN THEY
CAN SCRIPT THEM OUT, WHICH WE
SAW AT THE DASH EARLIER IN THE
CAMPAIGN WITH JOE BIDEN, BUT
WHEN YOU START GETTING INTO
POLICY -- DON'T TAKE MY WORD FOR
IT, LOOK AT HER PEOPLE.
HER PEOPLE DON'T EVEN TRUST HER
TO ANSWER THE QUESTION.
YOU CLEARLY HEAR THE QUESTION.
>> THE NEWLY BOOSTED
DAGEN McDOWELL -- HOW DID YOU
FEEL -- HERE THE EXCHANGE THEIR?
>> I WATCHED THE WHOLE THING
TWICE.
HE WAS HAND FEEDING THE
VICE PRESIDENT MARSHMALLOWS.
THE ENTIRE INTERVIEW.
HE HAS THE SAME QUESTION OVER
AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
AND ACTUALLY A GOOD INTERVIEWER
JUST MOVE ON RATHER THAN KEEP
CONTINUING TO BRING UP
JOE MANCHIN, JOE MANCHIN,
JOE MANCHIN.
SHE WENT INTO A FIVE MINUTE
SOLILOQUY AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE INTERVIEW AND THEN AT THE
END JUST REPEATED THE EXACT SAME
THING SHE HAD SAID AT THE
BEGINNING.
CHARLEMAGNE KEPT ASKING, WHEN
ARE WE GOING TO GET A REAL --
GET REAL WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND KNOW THAT JOE MANCHIN
IS RUINING THE COUNTRY.
HE IS STOPPING PROGRESS AND
RUINING DEMOCRACY.
HE JUST WENT ON, AND ON, AND ON
PIER THE WHOLE THING WAS JUST...
>> I DO AGREE WITH THE FIRST
ANSWER THAT WENT WENT FOR A LONG
TIME.
>> BY THE WAY, WHAT WAS HE EVEN
ASKING?
WHY IS JOE MANCHIN TO HOLD UP
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S AGENDA --
KAMALA HARRIS SHOULD'VE SAID YOU
KNOW, SHE ACTUALLY HAD TO GIVE
IT A POLI-SCI LESSON IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE INTERVIEW.
DOES THE PRESIDENT HAVE A THE
POWER TO DO HIS BIDDING -- NO.
>> IN A MOMENT HERE, IT COULD BE
THE REMATCH OF THE CENTURY, THIS
CENTURY IN FACT.
AND ABOUT 2024.
♪ ♪
Ho ho ho!
Not again.
Oh no.
For the gifts you
won't forget.
The Mercedes-Benz
Winter Event.
When we started
our business
we were paying an arm
and a leg for postage.
I remember setting up
ShipStation.
One or two clicks
and everything was
up and running.
I was printing out labels
and saving money.
ShipStation saves
us so much time.
It makes it really
easy and seamless.
Pick an order,
print everything
you need,
slap the label
onto the box,
and it's ready
to go.
Our costs for shipping
were cut in half.
Just like that.
ShipStation.
The #1 choice
of online sellers.
Go to ShipStation.com/try
and get 2 months free.
♪ ♪
>> Greg: IT IS THE REMATCH
THAT COULD SINGLE THE END OF
TIME SPREAD DONALD TRUMP AND
HILLARY CLINTON IN 2024.
>> HILLARY CLINTON SAID THAT IF
YOU WIN AGAIN, IT IS THE END OF
DEMOCRACY.
WILL THIS BE A REMATCH?
>> I HAVE NO IDEA, I HOPE SO.
I WOULD LIKE THAT.
THE WOMAN IS AS CROOKED AS COULD
BE.
>> Greg: I MISS THAT.
WE DON'T DESERVE HIM.
THERE IS SPECULATION THAT
HILLARY IS GEARING UP FOR
ANOTHER RUN AFTER A NEW ROUND OF
TV APPEARANCES WHERE SHE KEEPS
THROWING JOBS AT TRIAL.
>> IF I WERE A BETTING PERSON
COME I WOULD SAY TRUMP IS GOING
TO RUN AGAIN.
THIS IS A MAKE OR BREAK POINT.
ARE WE GOING TO GIVE IN TO ALL
OF THIS -- ALL OF THESE LIES IN
THIS DISINFORMATION AND THIS
ORGANIZED EFFORT TO UNDERMINE
OUR INSTITUTIONS?
ARE WE GOING TO STAND UP TO IT?
>> Greg: I'M HAPPY SHE BROUGHT
UP THE RUSSIAN COLLUSION HOAX.
IF YOU FOLLOW THE ARC OF A
PERFECT STORY THAT FOLLOWS THAT
SCRIPT, BEGINNING, MIDDLE, AND
END, THIS IS THE END.
THIS IS EXACTLY -- IT FITS --
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT WE ARE
SUPPOSED TO GET.
>> YES.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WE KNOW SHE'S MOANING AGAIN
BECAUSE SHE HOT ROLLS HER HAIR.
LOTS OF QUESTIONS ABOUT JEFFREY
A PRISTINE IF SHE DECIDES TO RUN
AGAIN.
I WILL LOOK FORWARD TO THAT.
BUT TO ME, THIS SEEMS LIKE A
SEQUEL BATTLEFIELD EARTH 2 THAT
NOBODY IS REALLY ASKING FOR.
>> HERE'S THE DEAL, LAWRENCE,
FOX DOESN'T NEED THIS.
WE ARE HUGE.
WE ARE THE GREATEST CABLE NEWS
NETWORK THAT WILL EVER BE.
BUT CNN AND MSNBC NEED THIS.
THEY NEED -- CNN IS ABOUT A
MONTH AWAY FROM CLOSING UP SHOP.
THIS COULD SAVE THEM.
>> THIS IS ANOTHER ROCKY FIGHT.
HERE'S THE DEAL, HILLARY IS NOT
OVER THIS.
BUT SO ARE THE DEMOCRATIC
VOTERS, THEY ARE NOT OVER IT.
THE THOUGHT OF THAT ELECTION
GIVES THEM PTSD.
I DON'T THINK THAT SHE WOULD BE
ABLE TO GET THE NOMINATION
BECAUSE SHE IS A PERSON THAT
COULDN'T BE DONALD.
IT WILL FOREVER BE ON HER
RECORD.
>> Greg: SHE GIVES THEM PTSD,
BILL GIVES THEM...
[LAUGHTER]
DON'T WE NEED NEW BLOOD?
>> I GUESS.
I DID THE NUMBERS THOUGH.
TRUMP WOULD BE 78.
HILLARY WOULD BE 77.
JOE BIDEN WOULD BE 82.
KAMALA HARRIS APPROVAL RATING AS
OF LAST WEEK WAS 28%.
I DID A GREG GUTFELD, AS GREG
WOULD SAY, IF THIS WERE A FIGHT
AT THE PLAYGROUND, EVERYONE
WOULD HAVE A BLACK EYE.
TRUMP IS TIED TO JANUARY 1ST AND
HE LOST TO BIDEN.
GAVIN NEWSOM HAS ISSUES COMING
OUT OF COVID.
SCHOOLS, MANDATES -- HE HAS TO
GO TO PORT IN CALIFORNIA, RIGHT?
YES, IT'S ENTIRELY POSSIBLE, BUT
I AGREE WITH YOU.
IT WOULD BE REALLY GOOD.
>> Greg: HE BROUGHT UP
GAVIN NEWSOM WHICH IS THE
FOREFRONT RUNNER.
AND RON DeSANTIS -- COULD YOU
IMAGINE THAT?
AS A GOVERNOR VERSUS GOVERNOR,
DO DIFFERENT APPROACHES.
>> Dana: I'D LIKE TO GO ON THE
RECORD AND SAY THAT HOT ROLLERS
WERE SOME OF THE BEST INVENTIONS
EVER AND I THINK THEY SHOULD
MAKE A COMEBACK.
SECONDLY, YOU SAID THE
DEMOCRATS -- I THINK THAT'S
TRUE.
I DO NOT THINK THAT SHE WIPES
THE SLATE CLEAN FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
I THINK THEY WOULD BE DREADING
THAT.
THE OTHER THING IS THAT
HILLARY CLINTON CAN'T CATCH A
BREAK.
SHE WANTED TO MAKE NEWS ON
SUNDAY ABOUT HOW SHE MIGHT PUT
HER SHOW BACK ON THE WATER, BUT
JOE MANCHIN STOLE ALL HER
THUNDER.
>> Greg: I DON'T LIKE IT WHEN
YOU USE THINGS THAT CONTRADICT
WHAT I SAID LATER.
PEOPLE AREN'T -- THE BLOCKS ARE
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT.
SO WHEN I SAID THEY WANTED A
CLEAN SLATE, BUT THEY WANT
THIS -- THOSE